[Musique]
ça fait trois ans de plus qu'on
a pu jouer ensemble et que ce
qui te donne c'est beaucoup de synchronisation
quelque chose que tu n'as pas un
football international je pense qu'on
essaie toujours d'avoir une certaine continuité sur les
joueurs  et essayez de travailler comme vous le
feriez dans un environnement de club euh donc la
compréhension entre les joueurs est
beaucoup plus grande et nous avons traversé beaucoup de choses
ensemble donc en termes d'expérience et de
pool de joueurs euh je crois que nous
sommes plus forts que  nous étions en 2018. Je
pense évidemment que lorsque vous parlez de
romelu lukaku, l'
attribut exceptionnel de la qualité exceptionnelle est
son nombre de buts, c'est un
joueur qui, si vous l'obtenez dans des
positions de buteur, son
taux de conversion est exceptionnel, je pense  vous
regardez les statistiques le nombre de buts qu'il a
marqués
dans sa carrière à un jeune âge et ce
qu'il a fait pour l'équipe nationale est
déjà le buteur record c'est
sa vraie
force à demain après le  Jeu